Blackbaud,
so as we all know,
Steve Jobs died this Wednesday.
He was many things,
an entrepreneur,
a visionary,
a computer genius,
and employer of thousands,
a nerd,
a father,
a husband,
a man of flesh,
sinew and bone.
Many of these things will reach into the
future and be his legacy,
but I think the final mark that Steve
Jobs will make on posterity will be
further reaching than we can get.
Let me explain.
So I have a number of friends who are
product designers for tech and
otherwise,
and they have all expressed to me a
similar frustration with the nature of
their field.
Things automated to last anymore.
My products become obsolete in a year or
let Celeste and both are certainly true.
Things aren't made to last.
So during the week I work as a
telemarketer and I talk to people every
day who's 2000,
five,
2006 model whatever is already having
mechanical problems.
Now with certainly true that the auto
industry could design and build vehicles
to last considerably longer than that.
They don't because if they did,
you wouldn't come back in six years to
buy a new one.
This is called planned obsolescence.
The origin of the term is credited to
Bernard London in his 1932 essay
entitled ending the Depression through
planned obsolescence in which he says
furniture and clothing and commodities
should have a span of life justice
humans have,
of course,
he also proposed that there should be a
special government agency deciding the
lifespans of products and anyone found
using a product past its depth.
They should be penalized,
but the more judicious ideas about
planned obsolescence stuck.
Now what should be said?
That obsolescence itself is an intrinsic
feature in any free market.
Accompany simply can't make the most
durable,
advanced product possible because it
would violate costs efficiency.
Basically,
the best possible product would be so
expensive to make that the term profit,
it's price would be too high for anyone
to want to buy a call.
That intrinsic obsolescence.
Now there's a third kind and it occurs
when a new product or technology
supersedes the old telephone over the
telegraph dvds over vhs and laser disc
mp3s over cds or cassettes over vinyl
records.
This is called technical obsolescence
and really the history of the universe,
the history of everything.
You can look at it as a process of
technical obsolescence,
so in the early stages of the university
just had basic element of those basic
elements.
Carbon step forward as the most
versatile because it can form bonds in
four directions over billions of years.
Carbon based molecules became more
intricate,
more complex.
Eventually these systems designed to
precise digital mechanism to store
information on how to build a larger
society of molecules.
This is DNA.
It's sort of like a factory that holds
precise records on how to build complex
systems of molecules,
so dna supersedes basic matter using
basic matter.
Millions of years later,
DNA produces that can detect information
via their own sensory organs.
These brainy organisms can redesign the
world in their own mind and put those
ideas into actions.
With this guy right here starts creating
mechanisms of its own technology.
Technology advances slow at first,
but then it gets more rapid and rabbit
and rabbit and rabbit,
rabbit.
What's next?
The integration of the biological width,
the technological
same make.
These were taken at the West Highland
police station in 1984.
You were there.
Same model were taken today.
You have to let me see my son.
He's in great danger.
Well,
not exactly like that,
but slowly and gradually we will take on
biological components.
My grandfather had a pacemaker in his
chest.
My other grandfather had a hearing aid
medal of honor recipient sergeant first
class.
Leroy petry has a bionic hand that
responds to muscle movements in his arm
and it's fucking awesome.
The relationship between the
technological and the biological will
mature in the years to come.
It will become more intimate.
Eventually our intelligence will take
advantage of the speed and power of our
technology and our technology will take
advantage of the amazing pattern
recognition of our intelligence.
We as humans will become subject to the
rules of technical obsolescence and
there are those who liked my friends get
frustrated at the staying power of their
products,
but with technology and technical
obsolescence,
the whole theory of design has to be
altered.
Maybe the goal can't be to design
something which will last,
but rather to have a positive effect on
the evolution of a product who defined
the terms by which we will continue to
think about it.
Designers of both hardware and software
will have a huge effect on the future of
our race.
They will be out in front of us
inventing and defining ways by which we
think about ourselves.
Now,
if there were only someone in our day
who seamlessly combined hardware and
software,
if there were only someone who
understood that the relationship between
these two things could be organic.
Imagine the future that we could expect
if there were only a man who set the
stage between the affair of intelligence
and its eventual form in a way that was
complimentary and profound and always
elegant.
And I think you still have to think
differently to buy an apple computer.
Uh,
and I think the people that do buy them
to think differently and they are the
creative spirits in this world.
They are the people that are not just
out to get a job done.
They're out to change the world and
they're out to change the world using
whatever great tools they can get and we
make tools for those kinds of people,
so hopefully what you've seen here today
are some beginning steps that give you
some confidence that we too are going to
think differently and serve the people
that have been buying our products since
the beginning because a lot of times
people think they're crazy,
but in that craziness we see genius and
those are the people we're making tools
for us.
Thank you very much.
Thanks.